at all these Publications want to
maximize their subscribers and kind of
like own their customer and stuff but
there's there's a huge number of people
who are never going to subscribe to that
publication so most of the time you
don't want to read the articles but
every now and again they've got like
some reporter on the scene at Solomon
news event and you and and they they
they're actually the social article
everyone else is just copying them and
printing their stuff and so you want to
so you want to like read the
Philadelphia Enquirer article and but
but you're not there's no chance you
would become a subscriber so they're not
losing a subscriber but they are
annoying everyone who's not going to be
a subscriber I'll paid I'll pay 10 cents
for this article whatever music artists
get paid like that already it's gonna
listen yeah a lot of Dimensions exactly
exactly and and there's there's there's
no losers here like in fact the media
company will be a winner incremental
Revenue over and above those who are
never subscribed to their publication
that's right